this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome again to another afternoon
sunset sapphire with us here in June and
the sabi sands must it my name is Steve
Faulkner Mitch I'm joined on camera by
Sebastian and the drone team is in the
other vehicle for a change or in Wendy
and please in through your questions and
comments hashtags fire lava follows new
YouTube stream let us know what you'd
like to see talk about we are seeing if
we can follow up on the little chief or
son of that amazing young leopard where
he might have been this morning we've
just checked the last place just to lift
him and he's not there so where do you
think he might be hmm I've got a feeling
you might have just turned back again
and gone back to his favorite what do
you think it is a very nice 29 degrees
Celsius 85 degrees Fahrenheit it's
blustery it's a good where the philippa
to be catching something
it hasn't been cold today well hasn't
been hot should I say so it's a good
chance he's moved and has been moving
and we're gonna go have one to look at
where Taylor watching all cuz he might
be there obviously we got to check the
tracks along the way it's the one thing
that we have advantage over these
animals with is they can try and sneak
in hide
but we get our nose to the ground
well we quite often can find them how
amazing was that Safari this morning
with James doing his thing at cheetah
watching on two crocodiles killing to
Impala in less than a week and believed
but I'm not the only one out this
afternoon to Sydney is awesome driving
he'd like to say good afternoon a very
very good afternoon to you all and
welcome to the beginning of the
afternoon game Drive
I am Sydney and I am NOT traveling alone
this afternoon I am with the sins of my
camera operator we are both going to be
with you the and follow us on Twitter
hashtag safari life you can also follow
us on youtube chat stream my plan this
afternoon is quite very easy because the
weather is nice and overcast which is
good for the animals I will be looking
for Tandy and Kalama I haven't seen them
for quite a long time I what I saw this
morning was a lovely sighting by Chitra
dam so I will be hanging around central
part of the game reserve and see if I
can find those two cares
not really at all is nice and cool
the chances of trekking today is perfect
I haven't yet spotted any of the animals
just want to try and see if I can find
some tracks here as I can see there has
been some activities happening
I am NOT alone in the reserve this
afternoon Steve is also doing some other
tracking on the other side of the game
reserve let's see
well nothing at the moment we are still
having a look nothing seems to have
passed by this way so we're just gonna
go have a quick look at that we're
watching horsey if he is around and if
not we're going to spend a little bit
more time in the area where the tracks
were or where he was last seen the good
chance he's either gone to one of the
watering holes or he's moved off just
slightly from where it was but who knows
here are some lovely Impala maybe they
will tell us where he is there is a
beautiful one on top of the second rut
is happening and these two males on the
right hand side two males on the right
hand side off scaring all the ladies
that's what happens when this pheromones
in the air the males get all excited
again for mating rights to the odd
handful of female that potentially
didn't get mated with
here comes the third went into the fray
from the side you can hear that very
funny noise that the impala make such
beautiful but yet strange animals in
their own right good indicators of of
predators surround and we have actually
got a couple other animals with them
over there let's go up to them shall we
as a zebra at least one zebra and one
Valle de beast seems to be a bit of a an
accumulation here of animals sort of
hanging together trying to shelter out
of this wind the juma migration is in
full swing at the moment just going to
make some space yet because those Impala
seemingly still want to have a little
bit of a go at each other here's a
beautiful zebra you can just see the
size difference of a fully grown male
Impala zebras are far bigger enjoying
the company of these others because the
Houmas were through two days ago well
the night before it's very hard for me
to remember exactly when because we seem
to be in a bit of a bubble with all
these rehearsals and early mornings but
when coomer's had a zebra kill not far
from here and no data to be a part of
the family of the zebra here cuz I only
see two zebras so maybe it was part of
their family it's hard to say but if it
was then the memory would still be quite
quite real for them
my safari you reckon now Hasan is
missing an opportunity well he would
really struggle to catch one of these
when they're in such a large group it
really is difficult with so many eyes
and ears and that is the purpose of
these accumulations is to spot the
predator gives you all more time to feed
and to get fat and healthy because
they're all fear lions if they come
through invariably that also also also
sharted any leopard that might move
through so it does pay a lot of sort of
benefits to them all to hang out like
this just sheltering from the wind and
the thickets there that's where we gonna
find our animals today hiding away in
the thickets kermy Hasan ahead a meal
I'm trying to think I haven't been with
him for this last week I think he had a
another daycare
I think it was on last week that we know
of that he had that the tree just behind
Gallagher lodge that in Ghana came and
stole from him I'm trying to remember
the dates but then we don't know what
scrub hairs and small birds his head and
also we missed him for a few days he
didn't come out of the block yet but I'm
sure he had something and we didn't find
him on it very hard to say but they can
go two weeks or so three weeks without
eating well they don't choose to this
itami are full of plenty for them the
accumulation of animals to the watering
holes as we've seen a sauna spends a lot
of time around
Vitelli watering hole and he's been
catching and Dakers by the Dozen it
seems and yet there's still so many day
care I found an incredible their
breeding must be really really awesome
because they're just constantly around
even from the drone we get caught up
with lots of day care we spot a lot of
them ideal habitat in and around a Juma
area for them and hence why we have such
a high density of leopards okay well
we're going to move off from our little
family unit of animals here and in the
meantime let's go over to Sydney and see
how is tracking ski
I am now on yellow road in the middle of
the game reserve trying to see if I can
find some very nice fresh tracks of
these cats as here it is the last area
they have been spotted some few days ago
so Tandy is with Kalama in this area at
Columba the little one so when they are
to like their chances of them to come
out is very high because yesterday I
haven't seen them and nobody saw them
yesterday which means they are some he
must have to come out for a drink or
maybe for some other hunting activities
who knows
rezulin the lepers they can fight very
hard and their fight sometimes is so
very much painful seeing because they
can screech scratch each other and they
some sometimes it results one of them
bleeding a lot on the face as they can
be able to use those clouds to scratch
each other as they're fighting so I have
seen a leopard fight just that it was at
night it was not a good sighting but yes
I also hear some other people who
witnessed those kind of fights that they
can be vicious sometimes
Haylee at the moment the game reserve it
is very much dry but this is the right
season for the vegetation to look like
this is normal because now we are just
at the end of our dry season anytime
soon we are going to get some face rains
and everything will get back to normal
they do have some of the are evergreen
trees the I can see which are still
green to maintain some of the animals
grazes is the ones that are at this
stage feeding a lot on the dry grass but
they gonna have to balance that with
quite a lot of water consumption and as
eat dry grass and they must go and then
drink a lot of water so when going to
drink that is when our predators such as
hasanah will be waiting for them to come
I've got a very beautiful bat can you
see that but the essence right on top of
the tree this looks like it's a
Battaglia and look at that that is quite
a very beautiful bed yesterday I have
just seen a juvenile Battaglia and next
one of the nest in the game Reserve and
today look at that one I have got now
the adults nice and very big you can see
there's some wind blowing there this
bears there are very good indicators of
the carcasses in the reserve look at the
color of the big knives and pinkish the
juveniles don't look like others they
look completely different as if there
are two different species so they also
like to scavenge the Battaglia's it is
here in Juma Game Reserve where I have
seen my first Battaglia in water bag
which is one of the area's not very far
away from Johannesburg the Battaglia's
we don't have them that side so I was
very lucky and these are very beautiful
birds
so I'm just gonna carry on now and see
if we can find some of the trucks so
will I will just now carry on and see if
we can pick up any of the tracks as I
still have got a huge responsibility of
finding ting Ghana and Colombo not gonna
give us any time to do tracking if we're
going to be jumping like this hello well
we are back at the watering hole we're
gonna see if we can find any tracks here
see tracks of a male leopard herd of
elephants have been through here to go
and have a look shall we
nothing in Viet but we know he likes to
hide in these bushes just over here okay
there's a track it's one track and could
have been from yesterday no very hard to
tell there's lots of animals on top of
it these bushes yeah he likes a lot
it's been quite incredible that he's
been around this watering hole for as
long as he has I find that quite
incredible the power of water indeed
hello Safari Sally you wanna know my
best advice on people and its attract
just be patient with yourself and try
and think out of the box you obviously
needs our debt learn the tracks first
learning the tracks is the first thing
and then being able to trail an animal
well that's a different story altogether
once you can identify so you get two
elements of tracking you get to recall
track and sign which is looking at a
track on the ground and identifying the
species and maybe the movement even the
sex and then you get trailing which is
the ability to to go on the tracks of an
animal and follow them and then find
them
that takes a lot of practice a lot of
time it takes years to be to get good at
that
people like herb you've been doing it
for 25 years or so I'll be doing it for
about 10 years and now we're getting it
we're getting there but once you learn
the area and you know where things are
that you kind of overlay onto your map
inside your head about where the animal
could be moving so if you do little scan
with that thermal in some of the grass a
sugar a pee a little touch
okay well it seems like the mahram seems
to have sorted out some of the technical
issues and Taylor mccurdy is going to be
joining us this afternoon
gonna be all well to them iron with the
giraffe the drive hello everybody better
late than never
there is a giraffe there many giraffes
they are plenty giraffe in the Mara but
I think I've told you this a number of
times and I think you've all seen it for
yourselves doesn't they're quite cool
when I suppose I better introduce myself
at some point as well as soon as though
we've just started the show
it's just I'm glad that the wind has
died down my name is Taylor mccurdy and
on camera with me today is Archie woohoo
and this is a live and interactive
Safari and it's great to of course have
you all here so remember to send through
those wonderful questions but so manga
said we've got lots and lots of giraffe
they seem to like it around here every
single day without doubt on the main
river road here in the mire triangle you
can find not one giraffe but sometimes
like 30 or 40 giraffe and that's a small
group there are quite a few of them I'm
hoping that we're going to see draft
crossing the river at some point maybe
some of the shallow spots but mm maybe
not right now although there are
enjoying eating on the tree line there's
another one they're just coming out from
everywhere perhaps perhaps the giraffe
grow out of trees no they don't I'm just
talking absolute nonsense
but this is very very cool such a nice
scene to see of course our chair in the
Mari
can hear lots and lots of cars driving
past us it's also very normal well
giraffe glass suppose you do like
giraffe a with a name like that you say
thank you for making my heart smile it's
a pleasure
I don't know how are you supposed to do
it I don't know how do these people do
that and they take the perfect photo
that's silhouetted my fingers always get
in the way anyways I'm very very awesome
I'm not sure what we're gonna do what I
do want to tell you is that yes Louise
I'm specialist at being awkward we
should all know this by now man I don't
care I just embrace it and what my
original plan was was to sit and wait
very patiently at Maine North crossing
because there was a leopard that had
killed a wildebeest at some point we're
not really sure when and we're really
hoping to of course have a look at that
leopard but unfortunately the Sargassum
live everyone's of course just sit right
next to us and then idle their engine
it's my favorite thing in the entire
world sorry I was just waving and then
reminding them that we did do a live
Safari show as well and that I can't
stop and talk to everybody all the time
sort of the hardest things to do is so
there was a leopard there was eating
world be said Maine crossing them aren't
you for how long like 45 minutes waiting
patiently hoping that there's wildebeest
was not going to come alive because it
would be scary but that the leopard
would come back and then I could hear
like a little sis tequila or a Warbler
or something a small bird alarming so I
know that that lipid is still in there I
also wouldn't imagine it would just
abandon a beautiful kill like that that
I could feast on for quite some time but
then some cars were there blocked so he
couldn't actually see anything so we had
to leave unfortunately but maybe next
time maybe said some point we'll get you
a leopard there lots around at the
moment so better keep watching every
single day every morning every afternoon
because you don't know when they're
going to show up anyways we're gonna go
a bit further down the road maybe we're
gonna see that serval again let's go to
Sydney who has got an animal that hasn't
no shape like this I have got the water
back now starting to get disappeared is
quite a very small bachelor head so The
Bachelor has are those kind of rares
consisted of the male's both young and
adults look at that nice and very good
looking round ring at the back which is
just a sign for the follow me sign in
case of a danger also when they are just
feeling very relaxed they see each other
from that long distance look these
animals can be so very much camouflaged
you can see now when he's walking in
between the trees even that white line
you don't see it at all
so I'm just gonna pull forward and see
if we can have a a good sighting as I
can see now they are trying to move deep
into the thick bushes
I am sure they are not very far away
from the water holes because that is
their special preference they simply got
disappeared I cannot see them anymore
so they've been feeding together with
some of the impalas here in the area so
the combination here is about safety
safety numbers
you can pick up a very distant ships man
here so the Animas touches the water box
for them to mark their territories the
male's they don't use urine they don't
use droppings they rely on their strong
body scent in order to use as as as a
scent mark
just fell into the artifact hold a
the animals such as the waterboxx if you
can check throughout the year
their bodies they're full of hairs they
are very much Harris with a fluffy has
from the neck is one of those animals
which are very much difficult to tell if
indeed they are in a very good condition
or not somebody else is true in our area
at this stage the animals various kind
of species they are still in a very
great great condition is quite difficult
to tell if the vegetation is dry at the
moment they look normal
so now I'm just gonna go and look much
further in the area but Steve my other
colleague maybe I don't know if he got
something interesting for you already
let's see nothing yet we are still
checking with nothing around and
watching hall so he's just gonna go
around the area where he Prasanna was
seen this morning see if we can get any
tracks of where he's possibly moved but
when it's windy like this it can be very
difficult to find animals they like to
shelter down in the drainage lines and
so free easy to just bumble in there so
without finding tracks it's going to be
quite difficult good chance he's moved
but how far exactly is hard to say but
we're gonna keep on on our wanderings
and see whereabouts we come up
we actually found him on the train close
to camp this morning and we helped just
a guide through this really really under
navigatable block towards our left hand
side and managed to stay with him was
quite incredible actually important to
use of technology
hello PD I believe your new view welcome
to the show that's a very good question
you want to know why the animals don't
attack us well first of all a lot of the
animals are afraid of us so they
generally move away there's sort of a
zone that you can get towards them and
then move away that's their comfort zone
and if you get to posts they move away
but if you corner them cornering an
animal is never a good idea these
animals are wild and if we had to corner
one however it might be that animal
would obviously decide to attack you
rather than well to escape so it's all
about space it's all about Nottingham
sort of squashing animals into a tight
corner and respecting them and
understanding their behavior so we do
understand the behavior of animals it
takes quite a bit of time to get into
that sort of state of mind a lot of
training required as well we don't just
have just seen people out driving and
now African wilderness without any sort
of qualification especially if you have
guests and if you read the animal's
behavior they generally are quite shy
and move away from you but eventually
over time they get quite used to the
vehicles and so you can view them quite
safely quite naturally without causing
them any harm and if you go too close
you're going to cause their behavior to
change and that's not ethical it's all
about ethics Archer and if you
understand the behavior changes you can
preempt you could make decisions so
example if I saw an animal and its
behavior started to change I just
switched off the car take away all the
influence that might be causing it any
stress if need be even move back but
eventually over a period of time the
obituary process sets in and animals
realize that well these that these
things in the box that are moving
towards us aren't causing us any harm
they're not stealing our food and are
chasing us they're not hurting us in any
way they're not competing with us they
eventually just ignore us and sometimes
you'll see how close the elephants come
to the car
leopards they come really close that I
really see us as a threat anymore so I
hope that answers the question but a lot
of the animals also they've become
accustomed to see in the car but if I
get out on foot they see the two legged
upright standing human and you will not
get as close to them as you do in
that's for sure because they've evolved
of the African continent with this home
in it there's two legged hunter that has
hunted them for a very very long time
and some of the vehicle they don't
associate that with us but we go to
bring it all the way back up to the
Masai Mara tailor mccurdy has found you
some spectacular birds welcome everybody
to the bird beach paradise sharing the
Mara triangle where everything is very
relaxing cool calm collected where's the
where's the pool boy I don't know what
type of cocktails birds drink but you
know I'm sure they'd like something
maybe they would like a catfish smoothie
no I do like the spot however because
every time I come here there's lots of
birds and they're doing nothing except I
lie I lie they are there they're
grooming themselves at the moment so
maybe this is I shouldn't call it the
beat the bird beach bar perhaps it
should be the salon you know where you
realign those feathers you know come and
get yourself nice and clean and you know
it was quite interesting in an amongst
all the birds how those yellow billed
stork we're looking at there's one is
that that same one or was it the next
one oh there it is look at this one now
I don't know if it's just dirty the
closer I look at it the more dirty it
actually looks initially I was like
maybe it's a juvenile cuz it's even its
legs are a different color but as Archie
is zoomed in I look at that filthy
goodness you need to go into the washing
machine bird to get those those feathers
nice and white again you're not going to
impress anybody you know that that one
that's what a yellow billed stork is
supposed to look like beautiful with a
bright red facial skin the bright red
legs and then of course a lovely long
yellow beak Roxy you said you love the
birds here in the Mara
yes I do too we'll see what we can we
probably try and do a bit of birding I'm
sure we'll see some superb starlings who
would like to see some superb starlings
they're very pretty I won't show you a
picture in the book cause I'll wait for
them to find some along this road they
normally aren't and then of course my
favorite of the
the black-headed heron thank you thank
you for looking they're so meticulous
with the way that they check every
single feather that they can with their
beaks and they've got interesting beat
shapes look at that one I can comparison
if we compare the beaks between I
suppose the yellow-billed stork and the
black at it here and there they're very
much different don't you think I mean
the herons the herons beak is most like
the tip of a spear wouldn't you agree
how it's quite sort of broad in the
middle very sharp and of course they
will stab fish with that and I suppose
the yellow-billed stork will do
something quite similar though they have
an interesting fishing technique where
they walk around with their heads in the
water this is one of their techniques of
course all these birds have got various
techniques and they leave their their
beak a little bit of jar and they move
around and try and snap fish up like
that Paula now you've said that the
stalk speaks almost as long as their
legs
perhaps I for one I get what she's
saying some of them look like they were
just resting slightly they they do have
very very long beaks long and all they
don't have as long necks is here and so
I suppose that beak length makes up for
it and helps for them to feed easier and
you can see that one at the back almost
looks like it's got a little bit of pink
tinge coming to your on its on its wings
breeding season must be around then only
the male's normally go it's lighter
Tindra pink when they get excited for
the birds have you ever seen
yellow-billed stork chicken wings before
there we go
pink chicken wings
Portland my favorite bird is not either
or any of the ones that we're looking at
at the moment we'll see if we can find
you one it's a secretary bird our chair
in the Mara you get them in South Africa
too but they're in the sabi sand you
don't see them as much oh look there's
gray hair into that's we're talking
about that even a bigger beak than the
black-headed heron do you know what I
saw today but I can't tell you which one
I saw I'm pretty sure so a fluff tail I
need to actually have a look at my bird
book and see what types of fluff tails
we get here but they're very special
birds they like to live in Marsh
areas sort of rocking where there's
quite a bit of grass around as well so
yeah so I'll have to see that would have
been there was a new bird for me I just
from its sort of flight in its behavior
in the long grass that was acting very
much like a fluff tail but I have to
check and they're just resting at
they're not nesting or anything and they
really are just bathing in the Sun hello
our dear friends the blacksmith left
wings oh how I've missed you so much
we don't hear them much air in other
birds are a lot louder and seem to steal
the show by suppose Ferrari sorry the
crowd of dust that they've left behind
there was absolutely spectacular maybe
that's why that yellow-billed stork was
so dirty
perhaps anyways Sydney is trying his
absolute basis afternoon to try and find
you some leopards hopefully he will I am
still looking for the lepers the
beautiful salamba and Tandy in the area
here but it seems to be very much quiet
no much activities took place according
to the evidence I'm seeing on the ground
I have not yet picked up the fresh
tracks for Tandy and Kalama this
afternoon
so I am also concentrating on some of
the warning calls and none of the
warning calls has been given so far
about the presence of these cats in this
area now
Jennifer there is quite a lot of
disturbances when it comes to the tracks
one the wind can easily blow the tracks
but what makes me to confirm that this
is a fresh tracks is the following if I
see that the track is looking fresh no
insects went over the tracks and is
still much visible I can see the fine
sand that is what convinced me to say
this is a fresh track but if the track
is looking very old is when you will see
insects going over the tracks and apart
from the insects wind will blow it so
that is not clearly visible so I have
got something now very much beautiful in
front of me here the battle zebras are
standing here waiting for us to see so I
know a lot of people they do have kind
of a confusion between zebra batter
zebra and the mountain zebras we both
have those pieces occurring here in
southern Africa in South Africa it's
just that here in Juma Game Reserve we
only got the bachelors Abra's so the
battle zebras
the difference between them and the cape
mountain zebras is that they have got
less black stripes around their bodies
and the mountain zebras they have got
lot of black stripes around their bodies
and the battles liberals their stripes
are coming halfway they are coming from
underneath their bellies and the
mountain zebras the stripes are coming
halfway down to their bellies the batch
of zebras their stripes they have got
some yellow with shadows on their
stripes and the mountain zebras don't
have the yellow with shadows on their
stripes and if you look at the legs
there the bachelors Abra's the legs are
not completely fully striped whereas the
mountain zebras the legs are completely
fully striped right there we are seeing
now be underneath
tail is one of the areas you can tell
between the difference between the male
and the female when the line underneath
the tail is thin is telling you that is
a male zebra when the line underneath
the tail is broad is telling you this is
a female zebra this animals got a very
dangerous kick meaning that you cannot
go confirm by lifting up a tail he is
now feeding on this grass is dry grasses
this animals prefers to feed on tall
grasses if you can check there now this
area is not like completely grazed the
grasses are still very much tall which
is one of the reasons why you see the
Zebras with the very beast because the
very base prefers shorter grass and
zebras prefers tall grass in other words
this zebras they go in front cutting the
grass shorter for the world beast behind
to eat there's quite a very beautiful
animal look at that
bring the zebra skin if you can check
that it does have two colors which is
black and white at me as if is a black
color with white stripes but a lot of
people say is a white except this is
white with black stripe that I'm seeing
it as an animal white with black stripes
look at that this is beautiful so in
terms of the eyesight zebras they have
got a very good good eyesight and both
male and females they look pregnant all
year round they both have a very big
stomach and they are not ruminants they
just have a simple stomach like we do so
there must be most deborah's not very
far away from way east now as zebras so
this is Emperor's you can see now
there's more further down they do they
work in groups
zebras they work in her arms but
hürrem's they also feed together with
other Harlem's when harems are together
then it call it is called a dazzle of
zebras different harms together forms a
dazzle
so now I will be hit any fresh tracks in
the area here
so I'm just going to head on now and see
and carry on with my trading
well good luck Sydney I hope you managed
to find Tandy wherever she might be I
haven't had any success yet with hasana
some tracks but not they're not that
fresh but it's hard to say when when
it's windy like this the wind also can
damage the tracks cutting the edges off
moving dust across takes away the
freshness and be quite deceptive
lots of hey you know we just came past
the site where the Oklahoma's killed
that zebra a couple nights ago and I
inna ended up stealing the remains from
them but there was nothing left I'm just
gonna go and have a quick look see if we
could identify if it was a male a female
but couldn't find anything they picked
up the pieces we sought from the drone
they were I Ennis to gets it all over
the place feeding on that zebra I don't
even know if it was a big zebra or not
all we know is it was a dead one hello
Michael no no luck with no luck with the
hey Nadine it seems to be off the
property wherever it is but no one can
tell us exactly where we will let you
know a promise as soon as we find one
you will all know immediately
so we've done an entire loop now hello
Monique you want to know about sheets
and I in a track so they're quite
different actually very very different
let me show you in my lovely book here
here is a lovely high hina track the
size is very similar I mean attracted
very similar but you see the back these
two lobes here there's two lobes and the
toes are kidney shaped and you can see
the claws cheetah tracks you can see the
claws as well but the difference is this
back here but something you don't notice
in the track here but in the sand these
areas here all pinched the sand is
pinched together let me get the cheetah
track now okay and there is the cheetah
track very similar in length but the
back pad is is parallel to the front of
the toes and it's got three lobes at the
back the claws are visible but there's a
lot of space between the toes and the
pad which means you don't get this
pinched sort of sand patch in between
there they're quite a clear print on the
ground with what we call negative space
here it is in the sand over there and
the mud is not a very good not a very
good picture to be honest but ochita
track looks similar to a very big
leopard track that's sort of been
squashed in the vice-grip just squashed
because if I show you the leopard track
there's a leopard track there's a big
male so if you go and squash that well a
cheetah looks like that except the claws
are clearly visible in cheetah and these
two ridges over here actually stand out
in the cheetah Jack because that is the
grip that they use almost like your
track shoes and used for for moving
quite quickly whereas the cheetah the
leopard doesn't really need high-speed
movement that they bulge out there and
they leave a very nice distinct mark in
the sand so I hope that answers your
question we are looking for any of those
Railly
but I saw some just before there that
not very easy to show you on the camera
in this light lighting is also very
important aspect and when it's very
overcast it's hard to see tracks because
you can't see the angle and the shadows
are very very deceptive you need the
shadows anyway we're gonna keep
searching here for a little while longer
and in the meantime let's go back over
to Sydney who's doing the same this
first version elephants tracks going
down there I am now still on towards the
west western side of the game Drive just
try and see I've got some tracks here
but it's not for the cats this one I've
got here still not winning with the
crest at the moment
maybe our luck is gonna be much more
twas there where we are going because
from down this side it seems to be very
much quiet
no I don't have as I'm not I'm battling
to hear the FC I'm not getting anything
from the FC at the moment we just check
it here
I am battling to get hold of the
question from the FC L know maybe there
is something wrong with my communication
decide the FC could you please give me
the question back I am not hearing
anything
I am not getting the questions so now
while I'm still fine-tuning my
communication let's go to Steve
well the gremlins are all over the place
we are back exactly where husana was
left this morning I'm going to have one
more little little peek in here
Oh Bree from where Taylor came on the
radio a moment ago and said he heard
some alarm calls around north of voyeur
til damn so he's following up we're
gonna go there now I'm just gonna have
one one more little peek in here see if
he's not just lying up oopsie sorry zip
we're not just lying down here in the
drainage that we can't see very
camouflage these animals ladies and
gentlemen very kind of flushed this is
an area that we spent a lot of time with
tandy and Columba the whole of February
it seems it's just this side and that
side it's really really cool to have
spent that time with her when the little
furball was just a little furball
there's nothing much more just big feet
cuddly little face
could be anywhere
okay well I don't see anything here
we're gonna go around to to avoid Taylor
again and see if we can assist Aubree
those alarm calls alarm calls are a
great way to find animals but tracking
is a good way alarm calls is a much more
real in the moment but there were no
tracks coming out I didn't find any
tracks so very hard to say he might
still be here and those might be alarm
calling at some other leopard that we
haven't been paying attention to this
morning maybe ting gana coming back in
this is Austin area attendee likes to
spend at a time but if he is around here
he's probably very flat so if we don't
come right by the watching all will come
back in this area just before dark as it
gets to that sort of time where the
coolness and the light is in favor for
the leopard and they will slowly start
moving looking for their meal
all righty
so how is everybody doing on this lovely
Sunday afternoon this Sunday in South
Africa
David there's a few the best alarm calls
our monkeys are very very reliable very
but high pitch and the monkeys also look
so you look up in a tree and you'll see
the monkeys and he'd be like okay cool
let's look let's look that way and quite
often you find them kudu and yalla also
quite reliable bushbuck are in the same
category although the other day we had
kudu alarm calling I was on tortured
with sensor and we had kuda alarm : we
couldn't find the animal so maybe the
animal was skittish and it just moved
away from us or it had been there and
the smells was sort of still around and
scared the kudu so they are quiet I find
kudu ambush bucket you're not a very
reliable in Paulo as well you've just
got to differentiate the difference
between the alarm call and the rat sing
call and when the alarm at the impala
alarm its high-pitched quick snorts but
when when he's ratting it's a very
similar sound with a small that's longer
and more forced that is my analogy of it
Franklin can be quite good but we've
noticed also that sometimes they don't
call if they see an animal they just sit
there and they freeze squirrels I've
given up on squirrels squirrels I don't
like squirrels
monkeys and baboons very good very very
good but birds make their free Wow gets
everyone's attention I think I got you
all there did I yeah that was the CB
even jumps in his seat
so the baboons are very good they also
will be up a tree and will look in the
direction what else I'm thinking said
can you think of another animal that's
quite sort of common that we better
utilize
the most obvious ones and the best ones
are there obviously this other areas
guinea fowl are guinea fowl are quite
good they do that technique but the
thing is is that do that call in the
morning together and they're doing the
afternoons together so that's a
completely false at that time of the day
but in the middle of the day you find
them we got to assign a dream 11 jitter
one afternoon or one morning because of
that but as the Sun starts setting it's
not reliable at all it's sort of a
contact call so that is helpful go where
birds I suppose also quite useful my
concert I've ever found anything
successfully using go away birds because
they move quite a lot and it's hard to
really keep up with where they're moving
franklin's would explode out of a bush
and make that like okay well we're going
to go back over to Sydney it seems like
he's sorted out his earpiece let's hope
he can hear what we're saying
my apologies for the communications
earlier I was experiencing a little bit
of a problem here
with my communication system but now I
think I am sorted and I am now carrying
on looking for some of the big cats in
the game reserve no sign yet of the cats
where I am maybe these cats are resting
not sure maybe they have caught
something
David the vendor name for a leopard is
my way where is a leopard
I've got some of the very beautiful
antelopes here with me I am so very
lucky today to find both male and
females together mostly when it comes to
this kind of animals Nuala's since I've
been here I always see the females
together with the young males but to
find three males together with one
female is something very rare so the
females don't carry horns at all males
they carry horns look at that she is the
only female I am seeing here if he don't
look nicely you might even think this is
a different species so they are not
identical at all so these males they
normally work together but during
breeding season is when the dominant one
will go then with the family for
breeding purposes look at that you can
see the tips of the horns are very much
white mostly when the tips of the horns
are like this it means that animal is
getting old and when it's very very old
the tips then breaks off look at some of
the disruption markings the markings
that are there just to confuse any
predator a very much Harry they've good
mane just like a mane Kim I also love
Angela's a lot they're such very much
cute and it's interesting seeing them
challenging each other for territorial
purposes they fight amongst any allas is
the one of the best fight amongst all
the antelopes
because is associated with body language
and that is how they provoke each other
I love Nana fighting's I'm going to
carry on now and see if we can find
something a kid ninh yours they browsers
they eat quite a lot of leaves from the
small trees growing but this animal
sometimes browsers and grazers they tend
to feed on grass when their browsers
sometimes grazers also eat some of the
leaf sometimes that is determined by the
season and what is happening in the
surrounding when is too much drought
animals they give us surprises sometimes
we see things that are not documented
happening so now I am going to carry on
and see if we can find something
interesting so now we are going to Mara
and see some of the beautiful elephants
of Africa
no no audio a good back so I'm doing
singing tests as you can hear cousin
aren't you saying you didn't have my
audio apologies I've got to prove
emmalin's the gremlins followed me all
the way here anyways we have we have got
like I don't know how many elephants did
you say a hundred hey Archie easy maybe
more maybe 150 elephants all in this
area there are so many it's one of my
favorite spots in the Triangle ever come
and visit and you just need to come to
this I don't even know what this Marsh
is called but it's beautiful and it's in
the Triangle it's quite close to that
all and all or gates it is stunning
and if you are an elephant and you like
to eat grass if you're any animal and
you like to eat grass why would you not
want to come here it's beautiful it's
lush there's lots of little depressions
and loggers AKA drainage lines and mud
wallows i mean you can have a great time
especially if you're a young elephant
you might want to chase the birds too
that could be quite exciting I'm always
up for a little baby elephants chasing
birds that's one of the most awesome
things to see now these are different
stalks these are white stalks or that
big one and then there's egrets at the
back cattle egrets so another stalk to
add to the list today you're doing one
on birds so far we'll see how many more
we can add up maybe we get some Skelos
to rockers and things hello little
sleepy pens that an elephant no not
sleeping just a quick catnap fair enough
now you can also see that the camera is
just moving a little bit like I said
it's been quite windy and now that we're
out in the open the wind has picked up
and our camera is very much exposed so
it does bounce and bobble around a
little bit
Archie's holding on as tight as he can
well how sweet is that noble in event
having a nap now yesterday we had a
funny moment we were actually like it
was during the one-hour NatGeo kids
segment oh my goodness it was very very
very very funny because we had an
elephant bull one of these balls I
suspect chase and a kid do not for I
don't know a couple of hundred meters
chase some female obviously wanted to
mate with her and she is having
it so she ran away Rosalyn now you have
a very nice question but Louise was not
very nice to me today Louise is
directing for all of you so Rosen's
question was about what is the loudest
animal our chair and then Louise quickly
commented and said accept me remember
Brent Leo Smith is still the loudest
thing in the world I kid you not when he
talks on the radio it can be on Volume
one and it's still blaze and Archie and
I got like nails on a chalk chalk board
so Breen started to defend himself
ha ha ha Sabrina's the loudest and then
you're probably gonna get something like
cicadas afterwards maybe a lion's roar
and though an elephant trumpet is fairly
deafening as well you know I'm trying to
think most animals are silent except the
wildebeest at the moment they just don't
stop making noise I just rang and that's
all you hear it along the river it's
just quite cool so yeah so everyone's
actually fairly quiet most of the time
that I'm making odd noise except for the
wildebeest oh hang on what's happening
here this is this is interesting ok so
we've got the big bull on the left you
can see him and then the one with his
bottom towards us that's another
elephant bull there now he's much
smaller in sort of height but he's got a
good set of ivory on him whereas the
bull on the left is actually much taller
and I suspect a little bit older and he
just basically showed that younger bull
that he was not happy with him getting
close to the cow that was just on the
other side no I don't know maybe she
could be coming into Easter us again I
mean no calf calf is probably around two
or three years old although she probably
would be already pregnant then you know
they have a calf every four to five
years and our chair living is quite good
so it might even be sooner than that
maybe every four years or so but he
absolutely dwarfs that car you're a big
boy
and he gets he's also secreting slightly
from his temporal glands I think he
might just be coming out of must and for
those of you that have no idea what must
is I shouldn't just be throwing these
words around it's basically the excited
state that the males get into when they
want to mate with a female
and that's one of the indicators as well
as a number of different things and the
reason why I think that is because he's
got some patches between his legs that
they're drying up so and that's the
other indication is that they dribble
urine
I'm so sorry Louise please can I have
that again who asked that wonderful
question about the elephants now I wait
for the delay ma you're margarita you
wanted to know if these elephants are if
it's just one family group or do they
belong to different family groups I
would say I reckon let me stand up
apologies I'm going to shake the car cuz
I was sitting down I'm going to stand up
I'm gonna climb out of the vehicle so
right hello
fix my hat I'm going to point now so
obviously we in the marsh great feeding
area there's lots of different animals
that are feeding in this grass everybody
was quite happy there's lots of water
around a lot of food they don't need to
fight over it so this should we start
down there should we go from right to
left that down over there margarita in
the corner those group of elephants that
looks like they could probably be one
family group must remember with
elephants they don't always feed on top
of one another they can also spread out
a couple of hundred meters and graze
quite happily but just the way that
they've sort of semi gathered and then
maybe we've got another smaller group at
the back there or perhaps they are some
bulls and things like that some loners
it's very difficult they're very far
away and then I definitely think we've
got a group here in the middle this
group I think would belong to one family
hood I'm going to go ahead and say we
maybe have four or five different family
groups of elephants that we're looking
at at the moment I'm also concluding the
ones you can't see on the other side so
I think and they're quite a cassette
they're quite happy to move together
they all got to slowly move back down
and into the forest where they all spend
the night you can see it's windy my hair
it's uncontrollable here in the Mara
just clip it
I've just got clips everywhere and then
there's just somehow finds ways to blow
out from underneath my hat I'm really
hoping we were going to get some action
with these Bulls though but it doesn't
seem like it
but a very peaceful scene nonetheless
it's always really nice to watch the
elephants but we'll probably move on
because I'm itching to try and find you
all some lions and I need to check the
forest line in order to try and find you
as some Leone's
maybe the triangle boys are around or
perhaps the Mara of river pride will be
about so and that's what we're going to
do now and you Ben you were wondering
well I don't know because I need to go
and find them so that's going to be the
plan now is that we are going to go and
find the Lions because that's what I'd
like to do and I don't have much time to
search unfortunately as we do not have a
ranger with us to accompany us in the
darkness because my vehicle does not
allow for it right it's a go across to
Sydney who is still trying to locate
those creatures with spots yes are we're
doing big loops and nothing of yet folks
but this is an area now on our western
side that is officially fully underway
with regards to winter you can see
there's not a single leaf on the trees
we're quite high up on what we call the
Catena or the slope and you can see that
all the trees have pretty much lost
their leaves as very dry there's a fire
index of 6 today and we've got to be
very careful with regards to to burning
because of the wind and the dryness if a
fire happened to ignite now we could
have some seriously huge amounts of area
could be burned down so we have to be
very careful and then is why fire breaks
get put in but you can see all these
trees months ago this area was full full
full of leaves and all that organic
material has fallen on the ground
there's an enormous amount of termite
activity on the top of these hills here
with really big termite mounds excuse me
and this is an area where we hoping to
find an aardvark at some stage we saw
one from the drone a few nights back
further north from where we are now and
this is an area that hookah more relaxed
to hang out because the the the diggings
have provided nice sort of holes for
warthogs in the ground and so we're just
having one little look over here see
anything
Seibert amazing how it's changed from
the summer months and that is why these
trees that you find up on the slope that
the red bush willows are such hard wood
because they grow in the summer and then
in the wintertime they grow very they
don't grow they just sort of got dormant
because there's no photosynthesis
happening they can't get access to the
water so they just drop their leaves off
and from an ecological point of view
very very important because all of that
is being recycled back into the soil if
you do find any plants appear with
leaves aren't well that means they've
got access to the water and they're
doing very well the rain varies we can
have a look at this little herd of
Impala that is enjoying the dryness up
here in any way any lipids the rainfall
can vary but it's anywhere from two
hundred and fifty to three maybe four
hundred millimeters of rain a year the
savanna biome can get up to about as
high as 850 but no not really more than
that but in this area doesn't get lower
than about 150 but you do get yours
where it can do to to drought and the
rains just don't come but this valley
needs a regular aid seasonal rain coming
in the summer months and we go through
wet and dry periods and we've just come
through last year I think this last
season is quite a nice wet period which
enables the animals to get nice and
bulky again and build up and you can see
these in parler are enjoying this winter
forage of grass up at the top of the
hill here they have the potential to be
mixed feeders so they can feed on
whatever is good at the time and there's
no leaves at all maybe there's some
small forbs that they're feeding on
there but I think they're feeding on
some grass a nice big herd once again
the wind seems have died down a little
bit just moving around quite camouflaged
actually I mean to our our color vision
they they kind of stand out but to a
black and white seeing predator and they
actually are quite difficult to spot
unless they move
with that the three toned sort of body
color and the back is being quite dark
the side a bit lighter than the belly
white so it's home call to
countershading helps them to blend in
with the surroundings see they're quite
relaxed there's no evident predator in
the immediate area well we're going to
leave these very camouflaged and voila
and let's go over to Sydney and see if
we can spot him with this camouflage
shirt I am now at the buffers book area
in order to see if I can pick up some of
the very much interesting cats here so
but for now I am going to show you
something very much interesting here I
will show you this termite mounds I can
see they've built quite a very big house
here not very far away from where we are
so if you can check here where I'm
climbing now I'm climbing a very big
house it's like a pile of sand here so
this is a big house it started from very
much low and it has been done by this
interesting insects they termites
you know the termites when they're
building this they have got a very
interesting behavior which is called
trophallaxis trophallaxis is where by
this termites they defecate the Queen
defecates and this youngsters the
newborn must have to eat droppings from
their mother and when this is done that
is when you get things such as methane
gas because when the methane gas comes
it comes of the bacterias from inside
the stomach of this insects this insects
are one of the insects which first of
the Inka Empire is insects because they
eat the wood this wood is very much
difficult to digest and because of that
they
have to get some of the digestive
bacterias so these digestive bacterias
they survive in the stomach of these
termites so when the food goes in there
is when is going to get broken down and
after that they will then defecate when
they defecate their little ones must
come on cue and eat straight from the
excretory opening it is called an ultra
for Luxus so they go and get these
droppings as they come out right from
the anal opening you will see them
cooing trying to eat those kind of
dropping so which is also another way of
these insects to minimize the load of
the droppings in the termite mound so
you can see these insects are very much
clever so if you can check their
droppings again is going to be recycled
and work because it comes out with some
of the indigestible material so when
they come out they take again the very
same droppings and they use them in
order to build the nest that is why if
you go in there you will not see any of
the frost France is just a term
referring to the droppings of the
insects so you can see that this insects
they don't only recycle outside here
they don't only recycle the vegetation
so the nutrient cycle is outside
happening
they also recycle their own droppings is
used by other ones inside and they use
the very same thing again in order to
build the nest you can see they don't
waste anything so they make sure that
everything is used twice or modern twice
again so now I am going to go back to my
search and see if we can find something
so apologies I am using the
communication from sensor so I'm not
using the communication from the
original communication cord so every
time I will be giving sense of my my
wires so that I will hear the FC asking
question
well load know what's happened they was
Sydney's signal he must be going through
one of those little tricky signal bits
don't worry we were right up on top so
we've got I think we got pretty decent
signal here keep going around Sydney was
talking to about a tumour man I was
gonna talk about one but he's done it
for me the aardvark could potentially
this is an area that we I'm pretty sure
we're gonna find one one of these days
lots and lots of diggings happening
around on the top here and we got one as
I said from the drone it look quite
funny because it's it's quite a is quite
a unit of an animal you're running
around constantly constantly Nikita I've
never seen an aardvark in the sabi sands
I think I've seen six six odd Vox in my
life and Namibia is a great place to go
and have a look I got two in the Kruger
Park here's a lonesome hello oh he's on
his own it's not a good idea being on
your own out yet and get very jumpy no
one to watch your back prime candidate
for a predator to pick off and lonesome
animal see how he's got to put his head
up and then listen and then he's gonna
put his head down but then if something
makes a noise he's got to put his head
up again so it's that time spent feeding
and with your head up that is important
to notice and that's what the importance
of being in a herd is is you can spin a
lot more time having a little sleep it's
the same as what goes on with us if we
go at camping Archer we go walking in
the wilderness and we spend the night
sleeping around a fire if there's only
one of you you're gonna have a very hard
time because someone's got to keep the
fire going and someone's gonna make sure
that hyena don't come and snatch a piece
of someone's face but if there's two of
you well then you can least divide up
the time spend awake three of you you
could divide it once more but if there's
eight of you well then you can each do
an hour in the night
and that the rest of you can sleep so
it's a very good way to think about it
for that one hour you can spend
defending everybody in the rest of time
you can know that someone's watching out
and you can go right back to sleep okay
well it seems like Sydney has found some
signal and something rather large as
well I managed to find one of the big
animals you can see is an elephant head
so this elephants are very much
stationary feeding look at those ears
this is beautiful this one is coming
right straight just want to give us a
nice posture for the pictures look at
that he's trying to pick up something on
the ground so this is how the sniff and
look at the tools I can clearly see the
toes so they use the trunk in order to
also pick up the information on the
ground here so they will know about a
lot of things let's see what it's going
to do this thing I stuck that stick to
the mouth is breaking it is not even
fresh as a very dry stick until sure
what this elephant is trying to do
look at that so they use these legs in
order to dig for the water during the
dry season Laurie the elephants they are
not monogamous so the elephants are
polygamous that is why you find them
walking in this big head but this males
they are just there in order to breed
but when it comes to the powers they are
not decision-makers they take orders
coming from the females which is a good
thing because not a lot of animals have
that you can see this elephant has got
also some dust I write on the body if we
can go up a little bit I can see there
is some of the of the soil is is hanging
there you can see that this elephant was
picking up the soil from the ground and
throwing it up to the body this is what
they do when they're trying to also
control their body temperature the
elephants can be very much destructive
look the little ones are playing there
I mean the elephants unfortunately they
are not part of the territorial animals
elephants are part of what is called a
home range a territory takes place
within a home range home range it means
these animals can just go anywhere and
everywhere for survival for feeding
purposes territory has got something to
do with mating and breeding is an area
demarcate at within a home range for
breeding purposes and the territory has
to be defended home range is not
defended and the home range can overlap
territories cannot overlap
once the total overlaps then a fight
must takes place
so it means now these elephants might be
feeding heading towards buffers who as
we are not very far away from the
buffers woke them and that is the area
they are depending on for water
availabilities so being part of the home
range gives elephants much more
opportunities to go and feed and drink
anywhere and everywhere because the
territorial animals they depend on sit
in water holes but when they dry that
they also trespassed and have water in
different areas look at what that one is
doing very much peaceful forget that
a safari Sully
they animals when it comes to the colors
is very much very much difficult for
them to distinguish in colors but yes
some of them can elephants I am not too
sure but I know the elephants don't like
things such as flashlights that one they
can be able to sense it they can be able
to see it so when it comes to the colors
not too sure which colors they can be
able to determine
you can see that this this elephant we
are watching now has not been going
through stress for quite a long time
elephants when when they under stress
you can easily read that from the side
of their of their head so if there is
any kind of gland coming down is telling
you that it was a sign of stress but
looking at this one I can see there that
there is nothing fresh which is leaking
down between the eye and the ear so it
means it has been in a very good
condition
for quite a long time now those that has
been under stress that is where you must
check this animals they've got to spend
I didn't copy nicely the name of the
viewer who asked question about
elephants going to must the elephant's
the ones that go on must a Jackson the
elephants that go on must is only the
males and this males they don't go on
must twice a year must is kind of an
unpredictable condition which is taking
place once a year for about seven
consecutive days up to two weeks some
can be less some can be more than that
so they reach maturity when they're
about twelve years after that is when
they can be able to go on must is a very
short period part by that period the
elephants are very much temperamental
so let's see now that I found the
elephant still not yet the cats steve is
also doing some tracking way is let's
see maybe Steve has got some of the
tracks already well I'm always looking
for tracks always what is this here
that is tracks of a male leopard heading
directly from from that direction it's
not very clear to see in the sand and
you can actually see it now over my
right shoulder there just jump out and I
can show you can you see these hyssop
okay so which one you looking at this
way this way looking back okay so here's
the toes the four toes in the front one
two three pads now the size now we
talked about what advice you have for
track someone was asking me always
measure it it's gonna take time before
you can see the track here is the let me
just get a little stick here's the track
here's the back and here's the front so
by doing that you can measure it quite
nicely and that's just about 10
centimeters that's easily to complying
and a leopard track if you don't look at
the size but the size of a lion trucks
fob then a leopard track and if I show
you here again here is the back pad and
see how wide it is but if I draw a line
there the outside toe look how wide it
is in a female leopard it's quite narrow
there that outside so doesn't extend as
much males just got really really big
feet and he has walked pretty slowly
because this is actually registering
which means that the one foot is in the
other foot you step on the footprints
and let's see if we can follow this a
bit it's been quite windy
it's kind of headed straight down the
road here towards the powerlines which
then often goes out west let's have a
look I haven't been on this road in the
last few days but they've come straight
from power lines straight from via
Taylor straight from a sort of
quarantine area where we've been all
morning
now I'm not ever going to assume I know
which leopard it is it's am a leopard
that's all I can tell you there's
heading in this direction
no one's driven over it Maurice is a
great question you know I don't know
what hosana feels but I mean I think he
does feel a relative sort of sense of
security knowing his he's in the area he
hasn't been given any sort of negative
feedback by his pops hasn't been chased
away he's had a few meals stolen from
him but all in all it's been quite a
nice sort of comfortable affair for him
I think it's quite off-putting for any
any young predator to be moving away
from an area that they're familiar with
and then they're still going an area
that they're familiar with and then
having to go somewhere where all the
smells are new the males are new the
females in you you don't know the
drainage lines the topography I think
that's a little bit unsettling but I
think it'd also be quite quite cool for
a cat to go into new era I loved going
travelling in new experiences or
whatever and that's a bit daunting in
the beginning but daunting you don't
know how to look after yourself but you
know we have to learn and he's learned
very well he's a very successful young
leopard but yeah I think he's finding it
quite safe and secure I don't know
what's going through his mind though but
he seems to be enjoying himself here
although his dad is stealing a bit of
his food but I mean if he was somewhere
else the male who stole his food would
probably do more than just steal his
food he'd probably give him a bit of a
hiding
okay well I've lost those tracks now but
they were heading directly west here
there's an ass raptor look at that
beautiful lizard Buzzard just land on
the top of the tree there and you see
that very characteristic black stripe on
the throat in the barred chest beautiful
bird very black eye that sort of pinkish
sort of sere but very easy to identify
by seeing that at that black stripe on
the throat I've got some white on the
tail as well it's a medium-sized one of
the medium-sized small Raptors that we
get yep and as the name lizard Buzzard
implies they do feed on lizards but
they'll feed on small birds on rodents
snakes he just took off from a patch of
this so I'm flying directly towards this
he's good to have a bit of a poop here
we go turn around there you can see that
stripe now very easy and very
characteristic I remember back in the
day when I was still training
my trainer we stopped at a bird like
this and he asked me what said I said
I'm not really into birds he gave me a
very stern look and since then I've put
in a lot of effort but it just takes one
bird at a time practice get used to it
Oh
see how he does that with his head
perhaps is able to sort of push their
their eyes into sort of a binocular sort
of vision so when they kind of move that
that's hard ways sort of movement we
almost think that they just sort of
keying in or or zooming into something
I'd love to be able to to do that with
my eyes Hey
said do you use mine to use my
binoculars anyway Taylor is in the Mara
and I think she's moved off from her
elephants and she's found a lovely zebra
who's doing something I love to imitate
from time to time in the dust
they see me rollin they hatin control
and try to catch me rolling trying to
catch me rolling dirty trying to catch
me I think I've always wanted to do that
and I've never had the chance to bite
bad edits can shake that off of my
bucket list but here we have some zebras
who are enjoying an afternoon roll in
the dust which is awesome I do enjoy any
animal that is either a bad thing in the
water obviously or rolling around in the
dust and it's quite funny and I've told
you this before and most horsey people
will know this or if you've owned horses
before when ones one zebra one horse
roles or defecates normally it's the
more dominant one they all copy they all
go and do exactly the same thing watch
now watch these youngsters we're gonna
try to probably sit on top of one
another and roll in exactly the same
spot but that seems to be a nice little
placing and kicking up lots of a dust
not if you are a new viewer welcome
because you're probably wondering what
on earth are these animals doing but
lots of different animals cover
themselves in dust obviously in very
different ways elephants will use their
trunks to scoop up dust and throw it
over their bodies however the rest of
them the rest of the mammals kind of
have to roll around like this and what
that will do is that helps suffocate any
of little parasites that are living on
their body so particularly lice will end
up being suffocated maybe the small tick
larvae as well however I don't think a
big tick like a bone tick or anything
like that or the soft grade ticks would
really be affected too much by the dust
but the larvae and the smaller mites and
things I think would definitely be
suffocated and then of course birds use
a very interesting technique of moving
their wings around and ruffling their
feathers which is quite great to see not
Margarito you're just making me thirsty
with your name thank you for that and
you've asked about the differences
between I suppose male and female zebra
and if males are a bit larger so
Margaretta it's actually quite difficult
to tell the sex between I suppose again
the same thing goes with horses and this
really just comes with a lot of practice
and experience
in looking at these animals typically
the stallions the males are a lot sort
of more muscled up they have a very
thick neck they've got big shoulders and
rather large hindquarters so you can see
the zebra on the right hand side is a
maid because she's got a bulging belly
there's a foal inside there
she hasn't indulged on too much grass I
don't know if there's such a thing oh no
I do oh yes I remember one horse of mine
in particular that indulged in too much
grass and otherwise it can be quite
tricky and if you also yeah it's
difficult to say and then normally with
the stallions they're either the ones
that are up in front leading the herd or
maybe in this case that actually looks
like could be the stallion just watching
keeping an eye on us saying you don't
get too close to my ladies those
stallions are very protective over their
girls so we call it a Hiram but it's
hard to say it right now but you can
quite easy if they're going to drink at
the water any sort of waters agent which
you got over there then you can tell the
difference quite easy a Buffalo will
spotted a little herd of buffalo just
resting up in the distance again we are
heading into the marsh break away a
pride alliance territory so I'm gonna
have a quick scan for them and maybe we
find them but off you go back to some
more elephants in South Africa the
elephants are very much stationary
feeding here and little ones are just
playing pushing each other which is very
good in order to maintain the
relationships here amongst this head it
is not quite a very big head small head
look at that
this is very much beautiful there's
another vehicle
hazal the elephants can survive up to 65
years what kills the elephants mostly is
old age when the elephants are very much
old they start losing their teeth and
when the tooth breaks that is where now
we are going to have problem because
they are not going to digest they are
not going to chew anything that is what
normally kills them they normally die
from starvation you can see those other
ones were just pushing each other
earlier the elephants are very much
pitiful animals can see they are chasing
each other until show what is the
problem see that is a warning that
something is not right there so when
they are not happy with something you
see they will look now is running can
see they're playing they're just
irritating each other those two so
elephants they are very much interesting
because if one of the female dies when
she has got the babies she can take over
lactation and nest the little one
so this clean is very much hard they are
part of the pachyderms those animals
such as the rhinos and what rocks and
hippopotamus and elephants they have got
very hard skin so now while I'm going to
carry on looking for the cats
let's see Steve s but a lovely coudl at
the moment yes we - it's very very
beautiful he's on her and she's quite
relaxed very inconspicuous when they are
in the thickets when they come out into
the open like that they're little
awkward walk their front foot steps and
then their back foot steps on the same
spot and they walk very gently
he is always forward listening to what
is going to be approaching in the
distance you can see the director
registering happening means of silent
walking a very long long legs amazing
jumpers could there's a magpie Shrike
following her around hoping for an easy
meal as she moves across the open and
clearing she'll feel a little bit more
comfortable on the other side when she
reaches the thicket
probably my favorite antelope the kudu
the second one coming in from the left
nasib noise he always must count them
lucid they're her favorite as well
the always miss count could you because
you think you've seen them all and then
suddenly more materialized out of the
bushes
min mu I don't think so I think you know
that almost constantly growing fur I
don't think there's any sort of sort of
shedding that happens they they just
have the ability to parlor a rector to
stand that fur up to allow themselves to
keep warm as a sort of buffering
insulation but it doesn't get that cold
Archer I mean you probably when you
watch me on my morning jobs you probably
think I'm lying but I just struggle with
the cold these animals they get quite
used to it they tuck themselves in
they're constantly eating a constantly
metabolizing so they're constantly
getting warm inside and that is what
keeps them in good stead during the cold
months but I'm not familiar with him
actually having a really shaggy winter
coat that that gets lost in the summer
they always look very similar the only
might see a little bit of a difference
in the early morning as their hair
stands up a bit more must lack with us
we have them what's the word
goosebumps what we call them kudu bumps
in this case antelope bumps their
beautiful spots on the cheek as enormous
ears really elegant animal and slowly
but surely they just slowly disappear
into the thickets merging with the
vegetation Linda that bump that you see
there is actually a line of fur almost
like a little mane of fur and the
purpose it serves is exactly camouflage
so if it could have had a smooth round
back it would stand out a lot more in
that vegetation but it's got this little
bit of hair on the back of the neck and
down the back all the way down to the
tail and what that does is it takes away
that throat that sort of that smooth
back line takes away their actual
outline so they blend in with the
background quite nicely if I could roost
anning sort of side on to you in the
thick bush unless you look really really
closely you don't really see its shape
or its outline so that's the major
purpose of that the stripes included or
break them up with sort of that the
parallel or vertical vegetation the lion
sort of blend in
so they lose all three-dimensional
characteristics okay so I didn't quite
hear what Lou said to me there but I
know we're going to be going over to
Sydney let's go see what he has I have
got a very lovely group of gurus you can
see they are right on top of the termite
mound they are watching the elephants
feeding you can see the elephant right
next to them this is amazing
quite a lot of gurus together watching
the elephants one of the animals who
trusts the termites because look at that
the whole family of kudos right on top
those those termites can be able to
support the 5,000 kilograms of the
elephant kudos they can weigh just 270
kilogram is nothing you can see that
those ants they built this they termites
they built this termite mound nicely
look at that kudu subside two feet there
now so you can see that some of them
they are feeling cold a little bit
because the hairs are raised the the
main that you are seeing there now that
line of s behind the neck look at that
that is beautiful that main is the one
we can use in order to check the
condition of this kudu that main
together with the stripes white stripes
you are seeing on the side of the bodies
will tell you if this code is in a good
condition or not when the coudl is not
in a good condition the stripes they
faint and also when the kudu is not in a
good condition the main behind the neck
it goes down when that maiden is flat it
means they are not in good condition and
normally when it's like that is when
there is a shortage of calcium that is
when they must go then and find some of
the old bones and chew them to regain
calcium these animals can jump very high
kudos can jump two to four metres
hyphens from just a standing position
so the male's they look very much
beautiful than the females
the child of the universe the koodoo
females if you look at them they are
very way much bigger than Daniella and
the color is different Daniella is a
reddish brown and the kuru you can see
there is much more grey Daniela's they
the tails of the NARS and the kudos they
look more or less the same because they
both have fluffy hairs but when it comes
to the male's the difference is that the
kudos they males they've got long long
horns and the spiral of the horns can go
up to three and something else is that
the male nyada's are very much fluffy
and the qoodles they have got very short
hairs so look at that together with the
little ones this is beautiful so now the
kudos might be looking for the benefits
because the trees which has got the
Leafs now high up they cannot access
them there the elephants maybe will drag
some of the branches for the could wish
to eat
a safari sorry that despite a very good
question you can tell the age of the
coudl from their horns when the kudos
are just about five days old after bath
you will see the buds the bath is this
place where the horns are gonna come out
and when the kuru is just about twelve
twelve month is when you will see the
horns starting to come out
when these gurus are about eighteen
month you will see now that their hands
are in are starting to cave in but they
complete the cycle of those horns in
three to five years in order for them to
get there all crisp iris so you can tell
the kuru sally at the edge of the
qoodles from the development of horns
look at that you can see these animals
are just feeding all of them are feeding
but they are not eating so this is a
part of the ruminants they can collect
food now when resting they can be able
to again take back food to their mouth
and chew some card this crews are in a
very good condition as if we are now
still during the rainy season
unbelievable that the vegetation is dry
at the moment if you look at the is Cham
the ischium is that bone hip bone at the
back
normally when animals are not in a good
condition you will see it together with
the ribs coming out just from the look
of the qoodles you can be able to tell
if it's in a good condition or not when
starting to see the ribs where the
condition is faith poor
Paula most of these animals they reach
maturity when they about two years but
they start to breed when they about four
and above yes so the level of maturity
two years they are going to reach
maturity but for breeding purposes is
going to come four years and above if we
can check the kudos and the impalas
there's something I've realized this
animals they don't give birth with quite
a lot of males the females are always in
numbers higher than the number of males
in these areas and which is good in
order to protect the species so the
ratio is that the females must have to
be a lot than the DEM ELLs
so I can hear that now some other birds
has arrived they oxpeckers so these
expenses they help these animals because
they try to clean also by the
inaccessible areas now I will carry on
and see if I can find any of the
interesting cats
let's see Steve on the other side how is
doing tricky cats indeed tricky tricky
cats well we're gonna move around we
come back around towards the watering
hole voyeur Tara and Gallagher Gallagher
watering holes just up ahead to add the
scissoring of sana was originally found
sort of this morning and then he moved
off but we know that it keeps coming
back to these areas because it's
bringing the animals so if you're not
being very successful out there well
then move it towards the water oh
there's one of the coolest birds around
on the floor oh no he's up in the tree
now said there is African Hoopoe pretty
is that it gets when he gets his head I
pluck that they're very excited and I
know if he flies he was too excited to
stay on camera for very long I think
he's a bit nervous a little bit nervous
he didn't do his hair this morning it
was a little bit it was a couple out of
place so on that note talking about the
animals it's been pretty quiet an animal
front the winders dropped down so I
think they might start moving out of the
sort of these drainage depressions where
they're being hiding away and it's going
to be time to come and drink because as
soon as the wind starts dropping it's
kind of characteristic the summer
afternoon the wind really dies down and
then it means it's a little bit safer
out there for them to be moving when you
can't hear anything because the wind is
blowing all the leaves and rustling all
the grass it's a tricky tricky business
but you a lot of these animals have to
drink everyday and that is why the
leopards lie upon ambush in and around
the watering holes so we don't think he
killed anything last night he was still
looking quite hungry this morning
mmm child of the universe leopards are
very hard to track
we don't really track anything else
that's difficult so with honey badger
you know tracking honey badgers is
nearly impossible but you know most
animals that we track on Safari are big
five game so Buffalo lion leopard Rhino
elephant those sort of things so you
don't really spend too much time
tracking the small inconspicuous ones so
aardvark we don't track them we love
finding their tracks
honey badgers are but the amount of area
that they can cover in an evening is
enormous and so whether it's worthwhile
trying to follow is very hard so we
don't follow them but when it comes to
the big five are definitely cell eppard
of the hardest to track and we have
quite a lot of luck in this area but a
lot of the time what we do is we well
what Herbie and direction will do is
they'll suggest going and checking
places and game paths and you pick up on
their tracks because these animals have
got certain patterns that they like to
use and we saw it this evening or this
morning with the drone we were following
her Sylar trying to help Justin keep
with him and it kept popping down onto
game pads and then you go up here pop
down again so if you know where those
game paths are you just keep sort of
checking them because they're sandy
they're quieter for that animal to walk
on so you can have a bit more luck but
it's not an easy business I can tell you
that all right now even if you know
exactly where the animals going it's
still not easy there's a lot of time
practice experience and patience
patience you see Herbie sometimes
getting a bit frustrated when it can't
find because he's very good at it but
still it's still tricky it's still very
very tricky well we just passed Galaga
watching all didn't see anything but
there's no animals around which is
another worrying factor some zebra
tracks there they probably came down and
drank
important to just switch your favorite
on again it's just have a little listen
bring out out in a kudu or external kudu
very quiet it's not your volume but now
promise there's nothing going on out
here we've had such a crazy week I
suppose it's animals like it's Sunday
today we're just going to take the day
off
Speer enough fair enough two days of
wild dogs and lipids and coming out of
our ears
Oh Irene you ask such an awesome
question last night was it last night
was it this morning yesterday morning so
we're getting very confused because we
up first rain showers Irene we actually
managed to find a cat on the on the
drone and it was in an area where Tandy
until Amber had been and we were
watching it catch scrub hair or mice or
whatever you're not sure there's
definitely a cat's we thought I'll cool
then we call James in I was doing the TV
show he came all the way to the other
side of the reserve we got him in and
we've acted him a right into this cat
and he said it is an African wild cat so
a little bit smaller than Columba but
the behavior and everything about it was
so cat-like so yes interesting saw one
the week before as well up in that area
up in the north-northeast you do get
wild cats but they're very hard to come
by very hard I know Taylor had one
before she left for for the north but
I've only seen a handful in my life but
we had a a tame one in Botswana we were
looking after for for a research couple
there and it was a very cool cat very
very cool his name was Scotia and it had
been bitten by a snake and stung by a
scorpion and it didn't have much use of
its back legs but it was still a
phenomenal squirrel killer with that
good use of its back legs are still able
to decapitate many a bird and many an
animal I was quite impressed with her
but she'd sits outside the research
because that just not as training she'd
sit outside a lecture hall and all the
animals would be going
solutely crazy and she'd just be looking
up like what I don't understand so it
was difficult to listen to we've got 50
Birds screaming and shouting we're
trying to give a lecture it's it's
nonstop helps you to learn your alarm
calls there
we're good for the students
okay well we're coming around more back
to void Taylor watching I'll see if
there's any sign of the little chief
doing his thing no doubt if he is around
here he'll be lying flat in a bush
buying out a de coeur well while we do
that let's go back over to Sydney and
see what exactly he's getting up to
I am now going to focus much more
towards the western side of the game
Reserve as I indicated earlier and I'm
not here today I am now still heading
there make use of some of the roads I
have used earlier on on my way to that
side just to see if maybe the some of
the tracks on top of my tracks
nothing at the moment on top of might
sex all the way down from that side but
still I have got lot of hope that I
might find this case at this afternoon
so this is where I have last seen them
before the other colleagues saw them
yesterday morning
no sign at the moment
so it seems these kids are all together
both mother and cub
Monique I didn't copy your question
nicely but it's about tracking the best
way Marlene the best way to learn
tracking first thing is it must have to
be during the dry season because it's
easy to determine whether the track is
fresh or not during the rainy season
that tracks when they're wet is
difficult to judge because the moisture
keeps the tracks looks much fresher all
the time the best way to learn the
tracking is now during the dry season
and it must have to be early in the
mornings now when I'm driving I must
have to drive the road and come back to
the same road and check if animals walk
over my tracks and that is what is going
to tell me if the track is fresh or not
oh I'm just meeting Steve now he has
been trying by this side of the game
Reserve is coming from the western side
where I am now heading to he is also
doing quite a lot of shaking I can see
his head is of the vehicle all the time
and you enjoy
steve has been looking for the animals
just around here a Galago area so but
I'm going to chest pass any move further
down much more towards the western side
so I can
Monique to become a good tracker it took
me more than almost 10 years it's
something that I'm doing every day but
to be a very well sophisticated tracker
it does go with experience as we don't
only check the big animals we also check
a small animals and tracking during the
day when the Sun is too bright is also
very much difficult
so when we are doing trekking if you're
at school learning some trekking in the
morning you are going to get marks that
are much more less during the daytime
the questions when they're difficult
they give you high marks so now let's
see what is happening at the dam yes
well the Sun is slowly setting in the
Westerners and beautiful cloud cover
that's making it absolutely gorgeous and
slowly but surely that is well that is
for atella walk our Lodge behind there
and slowly but surely a herd of Impala
are making their way to the pan to drink
was a few there and there's one already
there those bushes they are the ones
that husana has been hiding in the last
a while but we can't see anything in
there we do have the ability with the
thermal camera as well so we would build
a spot him if he was maybe hiding in
there but you can't see him there's one
brave individual who's already made his
way to the watering hole they've been
waiting all day for the wind to die down
but they can still smell him the
residual smell of a leopard is probably
going to linger for a couple of days but
eventually the need to quench one's
thirst you can see how nervous he is
they same story as the feeding how much
time you can spin with your head down
very nervous
Tony New Zealand do you want to know
about in parlour versus Thompson's
gazelle I think that are larger the the
Impala most certainly in in the Maasai
Mara are bigger then within the Thompson
see oh there's a taker
here he comes that's the damn cam that
you've seen there in the tree with the
light and the die casts are apparently
water independent animals ladies and
gentlemen but yet they are constantly
coming down to drink constantly getting
smashed by wasana Tandy's favorite food
said right on cue is the day car coming
down a daring each other see they will
all come down together because it's much
safer as a unit coming down on your own
but Tony you're to answer a question I
think the impalas are definitely bigger
then then the Thomson's gazelle I'm
looking in my book here and in the
spring buck and Thomson gazelle are
quite similar I think in size and you
know they're almost half the side not
half but almost 10 15 kilograms less in
size the Springbok to the Impala so I'm
going to guess from what I saw when I
was up there that Tommy's were quite
small very fast agile animals but not
very big from a white perspective but
then parlour up in the Mara are bigger
than these runs down here and a lot of
that's got to do with the vegetation and
the food that they eat as a male they
kept coming in very slowly now they
never walk in a straight line folks at
acre you'll never ever see a day cat
winning on the catwalk competition
because they cannot walk in a straight
line they constantly jiggering from left
to right and when you track them as well
they walking they never walk oh well
he's walking in a straight line they're
always off the road again but constantly
up and down like a zigzag zigzag motion
and you see he's also putting his back
feet exactly where his um his front feet
were but the way that he walks he
actually kicks his toes into the ground
so you get more of a toe track than
actually a full heel track there we go
he's realized that he actually was going
that way the whole time and but he won't
go straight there he'll turn a bit more
they are such funny animals today cold
he's gonna come in and drink with his
fellow in parlour and then your honor
coming in the background but an animal
that is very awkward at drinking all the
way up in the Masai Mara tailor has
found one and when they go and drink
well it's awesome to stand and watch
there are quite awkward maybe we'll see
them drink but there's some oxpeckers
also on this beautiful giraffe hello and
there's the lie you know build oxpeckers
which is quite nice because they're the
more common ones aren't you and just two
of them now the reason why we've
actually come to this area was not to
see the giraffe now that it's become
almost a two-hitter giraffe but in fact
there was a male lion that has been
lurking about for the last couple of
days so I'm hoping that he's still
around here somewhere and I thought but
I think I'm wrong I thought that these
giraffe would quite easily point the
lion out to us by just staring into the
grass but that does not seem to be
happening today the giraffe and I was
staring in Assen than they're staring
back at the other giraffe which were
already in the forest so it's been quite
windy here almost every single afternoon
and I've noticed this particular group
of giraffe are doing exactly the same
thing they come through here they browse
and some of the smaller shrubs all day
long then there's a bit of a quarry
oh yeah which fills up with water and
then they'll drink from here and then
they go down and quite go and into the
forest but they go down into the lower
lying valleys what's that noise the boat
shouting maybe it was oxpeckers having a
bit of a fight although those oxpeckers
did a really fly off she's looking quite
round I'm sure you can all agree perhaps
it's a little a little draft developing
in her stomach that'd be nice because
we've been seeing lots and lots of
babies and I keep hoping to see a drive
being born again that would be really
amazing
now Siddhartha don't really do walks in
the Mara and there is a section that's
not quite part of the triangle
although Masai Mara National Reserve and
we can and beyond camp does some walks I
suppose yes in any walk can potentially
be dangerous but we don't really need to
worry because most of the time here with
a trained safari guide I mean if you're
gonna go on walking on by yourself good
luck have fun nothing probably happen to
you but obviously if you with a person
who knows how these animals behave you
know what the toughest thing is that the
grass is really long I mean I'll really
have to use a lot of self-control
self-control to keep myself in the cars
because I just want to wander into the
forest they look absolutely beautiful
but with all the tall grass around you
quite easy walk into a buffalo even a
hippo and that's not going to be
particularly nice so I think it would
depend I know some of the conservancies
and the surrounding areas do walks I
mean like this would actually be quite a
pretty area oh look there's some
Egyptian geese down there and trim up
man because the grass has been grazed
down quite nicely but any grass taller
than this wouldn't be very pleasant to
walk in or whatsoever that's quite nice
changing into Egyptian geese but I would
like to I mean sometimes we've had to
walk when you get stranded and stuck and
you don't have radio signal you don't
have anything like that then you might
have to walk to the closest road to try
and find help I've had to do that before
I think we've all had to do that before
the sea and the it's not something you
can do every day but in an emergency
situation I suppose we are trained
guides and it's better than somebody who
has come from very very far away to see
the animals for the first time wandering
around on their own that would not be
great oh my goodness
Sydney you are saving the day unless
I've missed some updates and apparently
you've got mr. T
of just survived now I managed to
relocate in Ghana I'm just trying to
find a better position here so that we
can have a good society can see there
now that Inga is very much relaxed I
think it has been a very long way for
him but they were aiso in his favor not
to show what is tiring thing Ghana today
look at that sign means now Kangana
might be thinking about going to the
nearest water hole which is the Calico
pian at the moment I can see there is
very still look very fool for me last
time I saw him a few days ago the
bellies were very very full showing that
King Rana ate a lot
but very difficult to see the letters
when they're laying down especially in
the tall grass
Tom ting Ghana is the dick of chum I can
see is getting very old beautiful still
looking very much strong although he
does sometimes experience problems here
and then leaping recovering but he looks
very much fine now look at that now this
is beautiful
so I'm gonna now try and reposition
myself and go much closer so that we can
have a beautiful sighting
since I okay here
now you can seat in Ghana very much
nicely trust Li that is very much true
is very much easy to pass this kind of
cats because they match the surrounding
they can be very much camouflaged it's
very much easy to pass him that is why I
prefer to track because when I see the
tracks I am sure he is there it's not
easy to see the cats from the
observation
look at that
the last facts I saw for Tinga night was
heading towards West but that was about
three days ago so it means it's coming
from that area look at that
this is turning
construct Pingala is one of the oldest
males here in the game reserve and his
body the build and the size is huge
compared to these other males that I
have seen before in Duma and something
that gives me a confirmation on Tigana
is that the left ear has got a cut and I
always mark that so I will show you that
here very nicely when you got a better
sighting again later on
you can see now 10 Ghana decided to move
and this direction of movement is to us
now they eastern side which is where I
am hoping we are going to have a better
sighting so I will follow him I will do
with ting Ghana for most of the time
from now
so now I will be heading and try to find
it in Ghana again but now let's see
Steve maybe he's got something
interesting on his side
let me see watching a nice thinking his
intention in the mood
well indeed it is the time of the day
for the leopard to be moving as I was
talking about earlier the animals will
come down and drink before the night
that efforts will start moving as the
light starts to change and the heat well
the day itself becomes a bit cooler and
how interesting that Sydney and as we
crossed paths if we'd only just crossed
paths a little bit earlier we might have
been the lucky ones to bump in Tim very
interesting well well done sitters well
we've got the sun's hitting a beautiful
cloudy afternoon beautiful coloration in
the dust
and once again at that moment in the day
to reflect on your day and reflect on
your weekend if you will any unresolved
issues any bad words with any friends or
family then hold on to them it's only
these moments that we have could be
grateful for them good company has said
good company sunsets cheers to that time
to reflect on what's important in your
life
lots of things out there we put a lot of
importance in that have absolutely no
importance really if you think about it
are you healthy
do you have loved ones around it's all
that really matters be grateful for that
all the money in the world can't buy
that beautiful
hmm
deep deep breaths and just another
moment of silence before we fly all the
way back up north to the masai mara well
sounds like a beautiful scene over there
with Steve we also have a beautiful
scene over here up in the Maasai Mara
and as you can see this lady is giving
us a very intense stare and she was
snacking on a small bush in front of her
before we arrived very very good
we just heading home on our way back
from spending the day out with the
sausage tree pride and for those who
have never does of you who have never
met me before my name is Scott and I'm
teamed up with James on camera like I
said we've been spending the day sitting
with the sausage tree pride of Lyon at
least two of them have Brent found him
early this morning and we kind of took
over from him in the hope that they
would try and snipe some of the herds of
wildebeest next to them but they just
slept the whole day and now it's time
for us to head back so I just thought I
would stop and give you this beautiful
view before we continue on wonderful now
I'm sure a lot of you have gathered that
the migration has finally arrived for
those of you who haven't well there you
go it's good that you now know and what
I'd like to do now is just show you on a
map and kind of give you an idea of
where most of the herds are coming in on
so this is the border of Tanzania here
that runs along the bottom most of the
wildebeests that have come in on the
western side of the river have come in
around this area over here and they've
slowly kind of pushed up all around the
kind of Salt Lake into this area and the
furthest herd I saw was right now upon
kind of along this road so they've made
it kind of halfway up the length of the
the Mara triangle and I can expect where
we can all expect a lot more to come
that's some exciting news there are of
course others on the opposite side of
the river where my hand is over here and
but that is not where we are exploring
at the moment most of the heads in the
kind of southwestern corner and it
really is wonderful to have them back in
town so very good the first time I
actually got to spend some time with
them was after dark a couple of nights
ago I spent two nights arts and trying
to find some lions for prints during the
TV show the other day but very very
exciting stuff and I look forward to
spending some more time with you guys in
the coming day sadly we had some tech
issues on this vehicle today so we
missed one another but I'll be spending
a lot of time arts and hopefully you'll
be able to jump on board with me very
good for now we are going to send you
back to Taylor mccurdy who I'm guessing
is also doing just the same as me making
her way home someone told me that there
was a male lion around yes oh no I'm
just making sure it's not one of the sub
adults from the looks like females me
but where on earth is the rest of the
pride most nights we actually hear the
whole pride roaring as well as the
triangle males but we haven't heard them
for quite some time so I'm confused as
to where they have disappeared and then
again the reports of the male line being
around which I have yet to see maybe
it's a male and a female that have been
mating perhaps that's what's happened
here but it is a beautiful picture now
I've told you many times and you've
actually seen it firsthand
I have never seen that all a lot of
pride of lions take down a buffalo
before I've seen them attempted many a
time and be chased by the Buffalo but
I've yet to see them actually catch one
of these enormous creatures however with
the growing pride and all those
youngsters you know being quite large
there might be able to now maybe they'll
have well maybe some of these younger
lions are gonna have quite a bit of guts
and maybe their inexperience will work
in their favor you know wanting to drive
the
and just give it a bash but there are
big and powerful creatures so it's
Buffalo and then you need to be careful
because they can quite easily turn it
the other way around where the predator
becomes the one that ends up getting
injured
oh hi bacon was almost like I said your
name just now but with Lion Air hi lion
you've commented on how much you quite
you like the pride of lions me too I
like them too yeah I think I'm actually
thinking they could be my favorite pride
in the Mara triangle Archie
do you have a favorite pride of lions
they're winners they were cool they are
cool not where they're still around
those two females remember that four
cubs but sadly one disappeared and now
they've got three and the last time I
counted the ona laws there was 16 lines
in total which means the last time that
I'd seen them when I was here previously
at the beginning of the year there were
17 of them so that's pretty good going
that means that they only lost one
youngster which is unbelievable and most
of those youngsters are actually males
so it's going to be a force to be
reckoned with and they're all around
similar age - I'm not wait to see them
all together again I keep looking for
them but no one has actually seen them
together now for the last I think for
about a week I've been asking around
people been asking me the same question
that's been a bit back and forth but
it's a very beautiful arch here so I'm
going to listen out before the roars
tonight or at least the whooping of the
hyenas maybe the hyenas will get
involved yeah there's also quite a large
clan of hyenas that move around in this
area
I can hear a jackal barking where's the
jackal let me stand up and have a look I
don't I doubt any of you will be able to
hear it because of the winds I'm
slamming her but it pretty much sounds
like a very sort of little dog bark the
reason I wants to know right is that
what a jackal noise sounds like Archie
he just looks at me I said Archie legit
he does this he just looks and he just
see it I mean eyes laughing must be a
jackal baboons
says Archie all the Boone's I could be
wrong probably in the forest somewhere I
don't know
a baboon gee it's a baboon Archie wins I
don't know why I'm taking you on safari
I don't know what I'm talking about
I'm not even a safari guide you know I
just arrived today and they just let me
be on the show feel like that's not the
worst thing I've done neither it's
because it's windy and now I'm going
deaf let me listen again it's a new
species I've just discovered the baboon
jackal that's what I'm gonna go with
Stephen that lion at one point was
looking she was also confused whether it
was a lie I mean a boon or a jackal but
Archie's right it is the more and more
here at the death sound like a like one
young baboon whining a little bit maybe
it has spotted the lion from a great
distance now anyways seen as the most of
the time I have no idea what's going on
it's gorgeous Steve he seems to be a bit
more clued up
I have got Tenggara with me at the
moment
Kangana is heading towards the direction
of the waterhole where I'm going to keep
following until 10 Ghana drinks listen
to that is that not nice that is very
interesting I love that sound
Dingaan acai I wish you could do that
again eh
so now I am going to pull forward and go
around so that I can again have a better
sighting of Tigana so I'm just going to
pull out now and see if we can
reposition yourself and see these
beautiful Tenggara
even the lepers can live up to 12 to 15
years so they can survive much longer
but the problem is when they start to
lose as well the truth it becomes very
much difficult you can see ting Ghana is
also getting very old but it's depending
on food caught by husana which is very
good because ting Ghana may be also fed
or Solana quite a lot before now it's
retaining all the favor that has been
done before
now I've got a very good visual on him
coming towards that direction I'm just
gonna try and position myself nicely
is slowly coming
and Nina Moe I did not copy that
question nicely if FCU can repeat that
question for me
need more the lepers they leave their
territories when the new boss comes in
which is very much difficult to tell
because it's not like an traumatic
decision someone else has to enter the
territory and take over the territory
and that is when a lot of them lose the
titles of being the dominant males in
these areas so that is determined by the
strength of the new owner and the time
when the new owner arrived so I can see
now that is walking around mocking the
turret or I can even pick up that st.
mark is quite very much strong so I am
going to follow him until I get to the
waterhole
I still okay there sensor so now we are
going to move and try to follow ting
Ghana
[Music]
it was a dial just jumped right in front
of me Paula that is true indeed is very
much relaxed I can see is not worried
about anything at the moment so I'm just
gonna try by all means again and have a
better position he's very much relaxed
not in a hurry he knows where he's going
and there's no much competition here
where he is he has not done hunting for
quite a lot of times now is just
depending on asanas food all the time
so now here I
a sealer tingle makes that so in order
to advertise his presence in his
territory so that is a way of
communicating with all the other lepers
in the area that this is my place and
I'm still responsible and I am very much
dangerous look at that this is beautiful
look at that
ting Ghana is very beautiful
earlier on there was a question about
how I see that this is t gonna suggest
that this stage is quite difficult to
show you I will show you again
so maybe when we get to the water hole
that the es don't look the same when he
has got a cut and that is what is making
me to identify it in Ghana
amongst the other lepers here in the
game reserve
so you can see how that tingle is now
going down that area there
so I'm just gonna follow him and see
he's not far away he's now getting there
slowly
so now let's again keep following some
going to Fulton gonna now
so now let's say Steve is also out
looking for something interesting let's
see maybe got something well always in
search of something of interest and we
decided why not pop down to the favorite
watering hole of the hippos down here
but what and they are we thought maybe
there'd be some more excitement
happening in and around but there's
quiet down here by the watering hole the
hippos are making a noise a moment ago
but it was just fantastic what James was
able to see this morning he got another
why he got wild dogs down here if you
did not see this morning's show ladies
gentleman need to go back and watch it
it was unbelievable wild dogs chased it
in pilot jumped into the dam that swam
with the crocodile following it and it
was such a slow-motion ending it was
really really cool if you didn't see it
it's very worthwhile going back and
having a look and something that you do
not often see in South Africa and James
has seen it twice in a matter of a few
days so very very interesting indeed I'm
kind of hoping me maybe we would have
bumped into some wild dogs down here see
if I'm just going to turn up a little
bit back I said we've got a fish eagle
drinking me
our favorite Little Fish Eagle here is
with his feet in the water often Eagles
will do that to cool themselves down you
often see Marshal Eagles doing that
standing in the water cooling themselves
but this fish eagle was actually having
a drink a moment ago here we go
and beautiful bird you never know what
you're going to see out on Safari
anything could happen I think James was
sitting in this morning watching the
sunrise and talking about a Jim no gene
and then suddenly wild dogs were on the
scene so these things do just suddenly
happen there's no planning there's no
pre-emptive nurses know email sent out
with a weekly schedule telling you
what's going to be taking place the
animals just do their thing but is what
makes it awesome to be out in the
wilderness and that's why Safari Live is
able to bring you some quite crazy
things from time to time you never know
what might happen yes
hippos are snorting the bush is slowly
starting to quieten down
I'm sure this fish eagles going to
finish his drink I'm going to find a
roost for the evening not long after
that the hippos will start emerging out
of the water for their nightly foraging
mgn you reckon it's a small tail on the
fish eagle yeah well I don't know him
you have another look sip quite a small
tail yeah it's pretty average you know I
mean that broad tails or long tails are
normally sort of for for bush veldt
species that or for forested species
short week broad wings with sort of a
broad long tail ideal for for dense
woodland areas and then long tails
fought for very open areas
case of the crowned eagle not the
crowned eagle the the Golden Eagle but
the fish eagle spends most of his time
in and around the water so it doesn't do
too much huge amounts of flying it does
a lot of perch flying so it'll sits on a
perch and then little spot some prey in
the water and then fly down so suppose
it's got just that the average sort of
sized tail and that it would need for
its flight but the pied coloration is
characteristic of most of the fish
Eagles you see in the world but I
suppose you're right there's no real
elaborateness to the tail there it looks
quite interesting on there on the
thermal camera as well they said Nikita
you're on and a half father fish Eagles
call carries all it's a few kilometers
at least because we often hear them from
here when we at our camp but that also
has a lot to do with the wind direction
and here we go the guinea fowl that
quite often if you have if we could go
to the thermal camera a loop there to be
great you can see the coloration of the
fish eagle with the terribly sorry
effects a thermal pictures not coming
through that side but the guinea fowls
have got bright orange heads because
that so they give off a lot of their
heat and their feet also quite warm the
fish eagles feet are also quite warm or
the legs anyway and that face area has
quite warm the rest is very well
insulated but they've all come in for a
drink and it's quite interesting because
if that fish eagle was in the tree or in
the sky it would be a predator to those
birds but it knows that being on the
ground or in the water like that once no
threat the marvelous are we see these
interactions between the prey and the
predator Gary I think birds birds of
prey daily I'm not 100% sure but I've
got a strong feeling that they will eat
daily they'll eat as much as I need to
so I would assume a fish eagle can spend
five ten minutes a day catching food and
it'll be sufficient for the rest of the
day so very efficient hunters there just
need one fish and they are pretty much
sorted for the rest of the day so it's
not a very very high appetite that they
have I'm in other parts they'll actually
feed a much larger prey in the form of
flamingos and then you feed on a small
amount of that before moving off and
yeah so lots of food around all the
watering points in most of the areas in
southern Africa you'll always find fish
eagles there but a very low sort of
foraging rate they don't have to do too
much there's hang around and they also
can scavenge they any dead fish that
might come around they could also go for
those guinea fowl if they were able to
sneak up on one which they do from time
to time I think even if I like giving a
fish eagle a little bit of a wide berth
basically saying you know who you are
stay right where you are
Loonette see the wingspan of a fish
eagle is about a meter out I'm going to
assume right now I don't have the
figures on me though but let me
double-check I don't think this app
actually gives a proper wingspan let me
have a look for I think it's about one
there's around a meter so about a yard
they're not the largest of Eagles
they're definitely in the small sort of
spectrum well they're a medium-sized
Eagle not not a small Raptor okay and
let me have a look see if it says
anything here about wingspan I mean it
says 68 centimeters but that's it's it's
hot
two and a half kilograms doesn't give me
a wingspan here I'm afraid I'm gonna
have to look that up for you but a very
common bird in the African continent and
the call is indicative of the of Africa
that if you've never heard it before I
will play it for you beautiful
characteristic African sound quite
territorial and then find too many
breeding pairs too close to each other
they demarcate their territory through
the calls and they're quite often will
also have certain battles in the air the
fish eagles are the masters of what we
call spiral spiraling and they actually
grab with their talons and they can spin
in a circle and it's almost like a a
game of chicken the first one to let go
kind of concedes the air space and then
they kind of move off so they know the
call of each other they know their uh
positions and there are balls through
their call and they're demarcated
territory through that call and
obviously food resource will determine
how many fish eagles you can find in an
area in very very fish abundant rivers
you can have a very very narrow
territory ranges and in the areas where
the bath appraised
little less abundant well you only find
one maybe two pairs in that area there
it goes
and out of shot beautiful as I said you
never know what's going to happen it
could just disappear
Oh mgn I'd love to show you a martial
Eagle they are the largest and the most
beautiful of the African Eagles they
really are something to behold and we
just look at the talons there of the
fish eagle you can see they're very
strong feet but the martial Eagle has
got enormous feet enormous claws
enormous talons on their feet which are
designed for breaking and severing
spinal columns and vertebrae of certain
animals whereas the fish eagle there's
actually got a very interesting sort of
non-slip pad on the bottom which enables
them to hold on to the slipperiest of
prey items and can quite often emerge
out of the water with a fish just held
on by two sort of talons with that non
sort of slip grip underneath almost like
a deck shoes if you ever done sailing
before but it works much better very
good case of evolution
yes Ellen well I'm amazed this is your
first one they are very common we do
find them at most watching holes you can
say oh it goes he's going for the heron
he's chasing a hare in there
now the heron is also fish eater and is
it said to the heron this is my pond
don't you come and steal my food and
that is interspecific competition right
there of a fish eagle telling a bird
that also feeds on fish that this is his
patch and they are renowned for chasing
away all sorts of other predators the
Pels fishing our which is the rarest of
the owl species we find in South Africa
on certain rivers in South Africa we
still find them but many other places
they just get chased by fish Eagles fish
Eagles actually out-compete them even
though the owl is bigger the PALS
fishing island is a very rare and
endangered our beautiful owl I've only
seen a handful of times but the fish
eagles are always competing against them
because of the food resource and there
is his surveying his territory and his
landscape and thinks I think Sydney has
got his IR light sorted out are we going
to be moving off from Chittoor channel
shortly but let's go up to Sydney and
see how the Duke is doing I have just
arrived now at Gallagher pen in order to
see team Donna drinking I can see that
he is not very far at the moment he is
nice and close he will be here at any
time from now since I okay here we are
now waiting for him to come he might
come here at any time I've just seen him
now approaching in between the bushes
but I can't see him coming out he's very
much relaxed he's not walking too fast
Rosalind daily pastors can go up to
eight to ten millimeters those are the
canines and those are the longest in
their mouth so those kind of truth are
very suitable to grab the animal from
the neck so the act like pins look at
that is marking every way
can see is taking his time the Bears are
making noise they are completing against
his presence and he doesn't mind them
Bobby that's what a very nice comment
he is Tenggara might be wondering if
asana already got something because
Kangana is not killing anymore so you
can see now that in Ghana is now trying
to check something so there's some other
guest here in the area where we are
he's not far away from the pan slowly
coming look at that look at how he's
walking he's walking as if he's about to
talk something he's trying to
concentrate as well on what is happening
here they decided to lay down a bait it
has been a very long walk because from
the beginning where we found him
he has been walking for a long distance
now approximately a kilometer and a half
now I'm not too sure why he started
walking maybe he has been walking for
more than that now look at that
I have not noticed in Ghana limping
today today ting Ghana is just walking
normally you can see also how is
arranging the legs
S is moving forward
it's trying to check something is trying
to sniff something not too sure what is
trying to investigate here you know the
cats can be able to these things that we
cannot see where we are because mostly
ting Ghana and the other case they show
me if there's any other animal in the
area apart from them
look at how lepers work softly I'm not
hearing anything where I am when he's
taping is so silent
I wish he can sew again he's trying to
investigate all these alum calls maybe
he thinks this alum calls are coming our
beard eating Ghana is trying to
investigate each and every alarm call
here maybe he knows that when these
other animals such as impalas are
walking in the takers in this ground
dwellers the best different Collins they
always complain look at that you can see
him right there beautiful
we can see that after eating something
they've got quite a lot of moisture and
they don't really go and drink I didn't
copy the question from Nikita FC if he
can repeat that for me
Nikita at this stage when looking at the
fitness of Tigana I can see that ting
honestly have got things not finally
digested in the stomach so I don't think
Kangana will be going for hunting
activities today and he has not been
hunting for quite a long time as he has
been depending on or sauna on several
occasion as we saw on the past few weeks
you can see that if asana was not around
Kangana was going to better because of
the injury imagined in Ghana having that
kind of an injury where it cannot be
able to chase an animal and nobody is
killing for him I think they're coming
back of asana give ting Ghana quite a
lot of benefits
Maurice the lepers they come and drink
they that is determined by the moisture
from the prey if they don't have a lot
of moisture from the prey they must have
to come and drink almost every day you
will see them coming in the morning and
late afternoon that is very much normal
but after having a meal with a lot of
moisture they get all the moisture from
the meat that is why after having a meal
the first droppings to come out you will
see them very dark black because of
quite a lot of blood you can see is very
much thirsty still drinking look at that
this animals don't drink without
concentrating you can see they don't
drink without checking what is happening
the eyes are still focusing its not
looking at the water you can see is
drinking but is looking above the water
can say that the folktale drama is
complaining about him drinking maybe
folktale drama also wants to drink there
you can see that the focus focal drama
is singing this song to say tingle now
you must go I want to drink as well this
is not the time for the folktale wrong
go to eat obviously it might be coming
for the last drink
he gave up so look at the ears now how I
identify Tracy the chances of
undelivered around are very much high
because this animal this leopard mostly
we are seeing them meeting accidentally
but they can be able to detect the day
the sense as they are moving around so
they detect each other's presence as
they are walking here so if you look at
the ear on the right sensor just show
that ear which is on the left
I just want to see how I distinguish
between Tigana and the other lappers the
one that he just moved now so that is
the ear which confirms to me that this
is stinger if you look at that ear it
has got a cart and the other ear is nice
and round so the e on the left is the
one which is showing me that this is
stinger so I identified in ghana from
the ears every time
so each one of them is good its own
sports pattern
look at that you can see now is just
sitting like that I'm sure that allows
water to go down very nicely now look at
that pose
and this is phenomenal if you can see
this kind of case they are more active
when the temperature is down when
temperatures cooling is when they are
doing their activities so I will be here
again in order to read what is trying to
think so let's see Steve let's see maybe
Steve has got some of the new updates
about his operation there no updates
leopard I think is what's on the card so
against chick you see if a sauna has
woken up and it's maybe moved back into
any of the familiar areas that we know
him to be in but it's quite interesting
because I was listening to the radio
earlier and north of the property pretty
much where they found tin garlic coming
in the guys are talking about how a
porcupine had been killed and dragged
north in cebu look so no doubt that just
in ghana who did that but i didn't think
he would have already materialized back
on juma how marvelous it is that we've
managed to have him for the afternoon
well then sydney but a porcupine that is
no easy meal I've once seen a lion
killer porcupine two lions young males
came up to the porcupine and the
porcupine it was that time of year in
these little pans have got water in it
porcupine ran up to the pan and put his
head towards the little little bit of
water and it was stamping its back feet
and that quills was shaking and shaking
like this and the first young lion that
went towards the porcupine has their
tent very inexperienced and would seem
and didn't do anything just looked very
confused to do with the spiny thing and
the second one came from the side just
looked at him smashed him on his back
pulled all the quills forward and then
just put him on the back on the neck and
then we watched him eat it and as he was
eating it quills were just falling out
of his face it was quite something
another six females materialized on the
scene he didn't share anything so that
porcupine didn't seems in German all but
I think it's all about just like if you
ever do have to handle a snake or a
monitor lizard or something you've got
to go in quick clean you got to grab it
with comfort
otherwise you're gonna get hurt so I
think that's what you did he just knew
he's probably done it before and it
worked for him just went in flattened it
picked it up and he enjoyed it that very
thick fatty layer on the back that holds
all the quills that looked very tasty
very very tasty indeed was one of the
first porcupines I'd seen in the wild oh
hang on there's a lion and look there's
another line and now we've got allied
with porcupine hanging out of its face
it's quite something to see it was quite
exciting Lee okay well are we gonna
manage to get him mr. cute I have never
tasted a porcupine but to to have the
defense that it has and the spines and
all of that but the quills on the back
must mean it tastes good I'm going to
assume otherwise it would rather just go
for some form of anal pasting or gland
for example civets they defend
themselves through through anal pastes
and glands just like honey badgers do
and things don't eat them there you go
you're just gonna taste revolting
porcupine is a rodent it doesn't have
any of those defense mechanisms so it
needs to defend itself and be quite a
large rodent it can't do what normal
rodents do and go under the ground or up
into tree or whatever it might be they
are pretty much stuck to the ground and
so to survive out yet
and obviously it's worked for many of
them otherwise they never would have
gotten as far as they have but you do
see many a lion and leopard shying away
from porcupines because it's just not an
easy thing to catch this spines but
there is definite technique and with any
predator you'll notice that certain
predators have really got the neck for
it over others almost specializing in a
certain prey animal
last-minute leopard for our side are we
going to find the little chief no doubt
that now his father's been found he's
going to feel a little left out of the
limelight this evening or maybe he's
just taking a break it's possible
possible it's also possible that he's
caught himself an Impala somewhere
nearby where we had left him this
morning he was definitely on a mission
he was up and down wasn't he said it
wasn't for the technology of the drain
it would have been impossible for
Tristan to have kept up with him so lose
say ting ting gana does have quite a
full belly and I'm wondering if that's
just from a porcupine it's possible
I mean porcupines are the largest rodent
I wouldn't say they're more than 20
kilograms at the biggest and I'm not
sure I'm gonna have to look that up I've
never ever thought about the weight of a
porcupine have you said no 15 to 20
hours assume at the most
subsidies tried the meat before in gabon
he said it's very tasty porcupines chew
but you didn't have to catch it yourself
with your face did you say no no you
didn't have to catch it himself
Carol fantastic folks for myself and
said it's likely a good night from us
we're gonna go back over to Sydney with
the Duke of Jummah have a good night
whoever asleep is just lying down now
because maybe had quite a lot of water I
am not alone here at this exciting at
the moment I do have some of the guests
coming from the other areas so don't get
surprised when seeing the spotlights
shining on this leopard so you can see
that the leopard is looking very much
relaxed so this is what they do after a
meal and after quite a lot of water they
must have to rest a little bit so that
the body can absorb whatever has been
eaten or something that he was drinking
you can see the eyes are even closed now
Nikita lepers they are indeed very
opportunistic hunters and they just eat
anything that is coming when he's
hunting for a Decker s crab here comes
he will catch it when Impala comes it
will catch that so they are very much
opportunistic he he had something not
sure what Exodus was but I could see
that how he lifted up the head there is
something that he picked it up look at
that eye these animals can see they can
see a lot more than we do it's very much
easy to bump into a sighting of the cats
because of this behavior of slipping
along ours you can easily bump right
onto the cat's line they are not even
seeing them sometimes animals when
they're surprised can also tend to be
very dangerous they are potentially
dangerous
not too sure if tingle is going to sleep
around here tonight it has been very
great this afternoon having all the
lovely sightings all the way from Maura
down to South Africa Juma Game Reserve
it was never easy for me this evening to
find any of the cats but I was lucky
enough just before the end to come
across King Ghana and the elephants and
all the other interesting things my
other colleagues has been sharing with
you since the beginning thank you very
very much for all your questions and
your commands meet again tomorrow at
half past six